well I can I can certainly try computer
programming is really a lot like writing
a recipe if you've read a recipe you
know what what the structure of a recipe
is it's got some things up at the top
that are the your ingredients and below
that the directions for how to deal with
those ingredients well it's very similar
thing happens in a computer program you
have you list out the various things
that you're going to be dealing with
typically and then you have some
instructions that say what to do with
those ingredients so if you can
understand a recipe and follow it in in
your kitchen then you could program on
that level but you can take it a lot
farther than that you know many of you
I'm sure have seen the the Iron Chef
show I love to watch that especially if
they are given strange ingredients and
I'm not sure I would like trout ice
cream either but one of the things that
happens there if you if you follow along
is that the Iron Chef
or whoever the chef is doesn't actually
do all the work they have what are
called sous chefs that they farm out sub
subdivide the jobs to and they'll do the
kind of busy work and programming is
kind of like that - you are the the head
chef but there are bits and pieces of
the computer out there that will do
things for you now it's not quite like
iron chef because iron chef you have
some fairly intelligence to chefs who
know how to coddle an egg or or chop up
a fish but your computer tends to be
more like a bunch of really efficient
robots but they're very stupid robots
and very literal-minded so you have to
at some level you know tell them exactly
what to do and but once you've told them
that you can just point to the robot and
it'll do the same thing over and over
and over again and do it exactly the
same and computers like that that's how
they are valuable it's sort of take
over all the boring bits of our thinking
and then you can kind of take it beyond
that instead of just thinking of
yourself as the chef that's in control
sometimes you want to program more like
you're thinking about how the food
actually goes through the process and
maybe even take it up a notch and say
here's a factory that produces some food
item Twinkies or whatever and you have
raw ingredients coming in it's assuming
you think Twinkies or food you have raw
ingredients coming in and they go on
various conveyor belts and get chopped
up in various ways and they get
recombined and there's this flow of the
materials through the factory and
eventually comes back out with a some
sort of a product that we consider to be
food
so there's programming languages that
work like that too that are more about
you just talk about how the data runs
around in the in the program for
instance your Excel spreadsheet you're
putting data into little cells and you
have other cells that say well just take
take make a little conveyor belt of
these cells and add them up in this cell
you're really doing programming even if
you think you're just writing Excel
macros so that's like a little little
Factory on your on your desktop they're
now going beyond that there's various
ways that you can get into you know sort
of more highfalutin concepts that you
would learn if you were taking a
computer science degree so the whole
idea of programming on this level is
you're saying one thing some abstract
thing and that controls a bunch of other
things and so the next step that happens
is that instead of just thinking about
data as the pieces of things you're
working with you know as strings decks
phone numbers whatever you start
thinking about those those bits of
recipe and those recipes can also be
considered data and can be sent around
on the conveyor belt in your factory so
it's
like little little conveyor that you
might have in your cafe you put put
little things up there that order things
up so when you start talking about
actions and abstracting them that you
can start talking about doing them
multiple times and looping and this
action may do this action which may do
the action which might come back and do
the thing and you get a recursive sort
of fractal pattern and so this this is
these are the basis of the more
mathematical views of programming but
you know you don't have to do all that
at the beginning you can just start off
with a simple recipe ID and add things
on as you go and learn as you go and
then you'll do fine